hi there I'm Aria and I was recently in
a video where I mentioned how I spent
some time as a monk in a monastery in
Thailand and people seem to want to hear
that story so this is that story
what are they sure that was it's
beautiful here it makes me feel like I'm
back in Thailand except there is a drunk
couple fighting and an Arby's down the
street so don't really have that in
Thailand my dad works in the hotel
business so we bounced around overseas
most of my life spent some time in
Singapore to Bali even some time in
France and then I also ended up in
Chiang Mai Thailand which is where I
finished high school and typically in
Southeast Asia young men before they're
married they'll spend some time in the
monastery to earn religious merit social
merit and blessings for their families
in this lifetime or the next because we
believe in rebirth which is a swell so
after I graduate high school I entered
the monastery for a couple of weeks and
my younger brother joined me to give
thanks and honor my parents for taking
care of me for the past 17 years which
included putting up with a lot of the
shenanigans I would get up to one time
my principal did call my mother in
because I kicked a sign down in the
mountains so once we moved into the
monastery we weren't made monks right
away
first we had to have our head shaved as
well as our eyebrows which was quite a
look for me but essentially you're
shaving off all your hair as a way of
renouncing worldliness and so once
that's done you wear white robes for a
few days before your big ordination
ceremony which is a prayer ceremony led
by the other monks and my family
attended and then after that I was given
my saffron robes and was officially
ordained I never really learned how to
put on those robes though they try to
teach me but I think they gave up after
like the second hour
you got to wrap it around here over the
shoulder it gets really complicated the
other monks probably saw me and they're
like that kid does not know what he's
doing unless you have the head shave the
eyebrows shave you look like a monk so
it's okay it's all good so once you
become a monk the routine is fairly well
routine you wake up early in the morning
at the crack of dawn and you walk around
barefoot in the local village collecting
arms which are essentially offerings of
food so basically we would form a long
line and just walk around the local
neighborhood and the townspeople would
one at a time give us alms into
individual bowls that we had so then
once you have all your food you convene
in a big dining area and have a communal
meal and then the rest of the day is
fairly relaxed you basically spend it
learning scriptures sweeping the
monastery before at dusk convening in
the big temple for a prayer session
which can last up to two hours which
could be pretty tough especially you
know when you're on your knees and your
your your feet are in an awkward
position but then after the prayers end
you return to bed and then you repeat
the cycle the next day but if I'm being
perfectly honest it was tough especially
at first you know coming in as a
hormonal teenager into this setting
where you're stripped away from
everything you're used to it got tough
at times and I remember the first few
days like I really had a difficult time
which sounds incredibly whiny
considering you're basically given food
and you spend the rest of your days kind
of relaxing and praying and meditating
but I think as with anything in life
when there's a big change in your life
especially as a teenager it takes some
time to get used to but I think that's
kind of part of the the journey anyways
part of the challenge right you learn to
strip away the these things that aren't
necessary in your life that's the beauty
of spending the time in the monastery is
that you learned that these things that
I was so dependent on didn't really need
them in the end
did I really need to spend time on my
space spending hours designing the theme
for my page no I did not no matter how
good my page looked and it looked great
did I need to be doing that no being
able to experience Buddhism at that
level as an experience I never really
thought that I appreciate as much as I
do now being third culture kids you know
I don't think anyone would have been
rushed just if we hadn't spent time in
the monastery so I think it meant more
to my parents that we actually had and
so I'm grateful to have had that
opportunity to do so and I still
consider myself a Buddhist to this day
because Buddhism in many ways is just a
way of life the principles it preaches
are just rooted in the core values that
we all every day should be practicing no
matter what religion we are be kind to
others be tolerant be compassionate and
there's something just so beautiful in
that simplicity and so if any of you out
there want to consider Buddhism or maybe
even spending some time in a monastery
please do so they would welcome you with
open arms and who knows maybe we'll
spend some time in a monastery together
hurry up
[Applause]